i don't think you've ever looked better
first of all i love the full beard i
don't think i've
ever seen you with a full beard
drew this is the came during the
pandemic this uh
and uh jackie's been wanting me to shake
it ever since she hates it
just for the touching of it all the kids
sonny runs up to me grabs it pulls it
it's nobody likes it you know the reason
women
don't like beards is because every time
you kiss them we get chin acne
yeah i know that makes total sense total
sense and uh
i actually without the beard tend to
spread acne everywhere i go
but i will say this i was watching
jackie
in um the wrong missy which by the way
was just exactly what i needed during
the pandemic
i loved it so much like
and i forgot that she's in blended like
i was freaking out like this female
comic is
bringing it yes yeah she kills it she
did kill it and blend it i remember
remember when that thing blew up in her
face and blended
i kind of had like a star struck moment
where i was like oh my god we got to
like do a movie with her because i think
she's a level
10 beyond in the wrong missy but
what i really took away from the wrong
missy is how hot
jackie looks jackie uh stepped it up
uh she actually didn't step it up she
always looks good
jackie had uh two cheeseburgers last
night
and uh and i lost two pounds
while eating the cheese i know what's
happening
i don't know but you know some people
have all the luck and the metabolism
department i'm not one of them i have
the metabolism of a sloth on valium
[Laughter]
well drew there's a reason i haven't
taken my shirt off in 14 years
we'll never stop eating the last time we
hung out was at
um a chinese restaurant and you should
have seen the spread
it was like it was it was epic
that was the best night drew man your
speech
you just drew gave me an award
to to be nice they gave me a nice award
and drew did the speech
and winged it i thought about it before
but just went up there and talked
and it was two minutes of the sweetest
the phrasing everything you did was and
i literally drew
was tearing up and my lip was shaking
because you were being so nice to me and
i ne i don't cry
i don't cry jackie always says what the
hell's the matter with you never
your eyes never tear up nothing i just
stare straight i'm i'm
insane but you were making me cry and
and and uh i and when i went on stage to
to take the award and i saw you and you
just got done saying i
i couldn't stop having that shaky voice
good
that's what i want to do it i want to do
it to you and make you cry because i
love you so
gosh darn much i mean literally i took
this this morning to let you know
this is the uh birthday flowers you got
me can you see that finally because they
went to the wrong
address whatever it's in my bathroom it
really is powerful it's
it's all you smell it put it to you this
way all i smelt
are those flowers in my bathroom that's
a powerful flower
well you're welcome jackie um by the way
did you
anyway um i love you
oh hey drew congratulations on this this
is the greatest you're going to make the
whole country happy
showing seeing you every day and making
like you do for all of us when we're
making a movie together
drew comes on a movie set the entire
mood changes people stop working they
just like
they just look at her like oh here she
comes the sweetest girl and you
go so far out of your way to make
everybody feel comfortable
and loved and important and and you're
being truthful
yeah every it is a team when you're
making anything like on your show i'm
sure
everybody's loving you there and i'm
sure the whole country's gonna just
just really enjoy being with you every
day buddy
you